[Music]
by now I think many of you are familiar
with the Google Arts and Culture app
that you can download onto your phone
and use to check your own face against
the faces found in artwork throughout
the ages I thought I would give it a try
and see what sorts of artworks and and
people it would come up with looking at
my face
the results were actually a bit
surprising not least in how Google
seemed to Center on one particular part
of my face so I started out with this
photo smiling and you can see what
Google paired me up with another guy
smiling who also has a mustache and
beard and somewhat similar features then
wearing the same outfit I deliberately
adopted a different vantage point for
the selfie and a different expression
and you can see that you know the Google
app mapped onto that sufficiently again
picking a guy with a prominent mustache
and beard and even similar here if you
take the color out of the equation
then I thought I'd pick something kind
of goofy-looking and shot this one that
you see right here Google came up with a
match for it again similar perspective
and you know hair beard an eye that's
prominent so it's zooming in on features
that it sees as as similar I wanted to
see whether changing things up would
result in different selections on the
part of the app so I put my glasses back
on
and this is a time when I'm wearing a
shirt and tie similar stuff is coming up
and you notice you know this guy's got a
very prominent beard and mustache as
well the glasses don't seem to have done
very much I mixed it up again by trying
to use a different vantage point you
notice I'm you know featuring the
forehead prominently in this and what do
we get again a guy with a mustache and
peered I think you should start to see a
common theme by now
once again varying the perspective same
outfit same glasses same shirt and tie
and we get a guy whose hair is a little
bit more wild in this respect whose
beard is a little less prominent but
it's still the same basic schema isn't
it so by this point in time it's become
very clear to me that the beard is
catching the attention of the app and
giving me a lot of results I thought I
would let my hair down and perhaps see
if that would make any difference took
the glasses off and so I got this
interesting picture of a young man
somewhat similar features I'd say his
nose actually maps on to mine now I take
a rather similar vantage point but you
notice that my facial expression is a
little bit different in google.maps me
on to somebody who has a bit more of a
martial looking face and I think that
actually does map quite well but again
mustache beard hair combed back so you
see those features being focused on
again I try another selfie in partial
perspective hoping to feature that the
hair a bit more and perhaps toned down
the beard but I get once again another
guy with moustache and beard featured
prominently it doesn't really zoom in
the feature of the longest hair but
instead gives me somebody who's got
medium length hair
my final attempt at getting some sort of
interesting match is carried out by
opening my eyes wide with my hair down
and looking straight into the camera and
it gives me this guy who has got a
somewhat different expression than than
I do
I guess his eyes are open wide and
that's what we have in common so what is
there to say about this app it certainly
leaves something to be desired
it Maps me on to men primarily I think
because of the facial hair feature
occasionally it seems to get facial
expressions that are similar to each
other linked up but sometimes seems a
little off-base given that it's Google
who's working with this you can well
imagine that they're going to be using
this for their machine learning and
gathering this data and using this for
facial recognition but at this point it
really isn't that advanced which is kind
of a good sign in some respects
[Music]